حذر الرئيس الأوكراني بلاده من
أن الصراع مع روسيا
لن ينتهي في أي وقت قريب، مطالبًا
الأوكرانيين بالاستعداد لحرب طويلة، ويحث
المسؤولون الأوكرانيون
الحلفاء الغربيين على إرسال المزيد من المساعدة العسكرية،
بما في ذلك الصواريخ طويلة المدى، في هذه الأثناء،
قال مسؤول أمريكي لشبكة CNN.  أنه من
المتوقع أن يتخذ الرئيس بايدن قرارًا
بشأن إرسال تلك الصواريخ قريبًا، هذا ما
قاله المسؤول، هناك احتمال أكبر بكثير
لحدوث ذلك الآن
عما كان عليه قبل وجود
كاتي معنا، كنا نتوقع
هذا لفترة من الوقت، ماكس لذلك هذا
شيء لدينا  لقد رأينا بالفعل نمطًا
من الولايات المتحدة، وهم يفكرون الآن في
أنظمة الصواريخ التكتيكية بعيدة المدى التابعة للجيش والتي يطلقون عليها، وهذا
تطور كبير، وهذا ما كانت أوكرانيا
تطلبه حقًا منذ بعض
الوقت، وهو يتبع نمطًا للولايات المتحدة.
تأخير النظر في إعطاء
أسلحة معينة تطلبها أوكرانيا،
على سبيل المثال أنظمة إطلاق الصواريخ المتعددة، ودبابات
أبراهام، والذخائر العنقودية،
وكل هذه الأسلحة تطلب أوكرانيا أن يكون هناك
تأخير، ثم في النهاية
تمنحهم الولايات المتحدة الآن، وقد
قال أوكرانيا ومنتقدون آخرون إنه لسوء الحظ
هذا النوع من الأسلحة  يمنح التأخير روسيا الوقت الكافي
لتحصين دفاعاتها، والتحسن في
الدفاع عن تلك الخطوط الدفاعية، وتقول الولايات المتحدة
بالطبع إنهم بحاجة هذه
المرة لمعرفة ما إذا كان هذا
ضرورة في ساحة المعركة أم لا، ثم
قرروا منحهم الآن الاهتمام
خاصة بهذه الأنواع.  من
الصواريخ طويلة المدى هو أنها يمكن أن
تصل إلى الأراضي الروسية، ولكن ما
يجادلون فيه الآن وفقًا
للمسؤولين الذين تحدثت معهم شبكة CNN
والمطلعين على هذه المناقشات هو أنهم
لم يروا أي سلوك من
أوكرانيا يشير إلى أنهم  استخدام
أسلحة أجنبية الصنع داخل روسيا،
وهو ما يعكس مرة أخرى ما
رأيناه من خلال هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار هذه، ومن
المفترض أنها أوكرانية الصنع
محلية الصنع، وأن الهجمات التي يرونها
داخل روسيا ليست من
الأسلحة الأمريكية أو من حلفاء المملكة المتحدة وفرنسا،
أي شيء مثل ذلك.  ونتيجة لذلك،
تفكر الولايات المتحدة الآن في منحهم
ولكن من المثير للاهتمام أيضًا توقيت هذا
الحق، فنحن ننظر هذا الصباح إلى
المحادثات بين روسيا
وكوريا الشمالية، ومن المفترض أن يكون هناك بعض القلق
هنا من أن الولايات المتحدة بحاجة إلى
تكثيف جهودها.  العمل على دعم أوكرانيا بطرق أكثر
من مجرد الدعم السياسي المعنوي ولكن
أيضًا تقديم هذه الأسلحة التي
طلبتها أوكرانيا حقًا وماذا
تفهم ما أعنيه ماذا
تتوقع أن تخرج من هذه المحادثات مع
كوريا الشمالية ما هي نوعية الأشياء؟  من
الواضح أن هناك بعض الاحتياجات العملية للغاية
هنا، وأنت تعلم أن روسيا
تبحث عن بعض الذخيرة التي تحتاجها
للحصول عليها للحرب في أوكرانيا،
وهناك مخاوف حقيقية بشأن الأسئلة حول ما
إذا كانت هذه أشياء عملية أم لا
إذا حصلوا على الأسلحة
والذخيرة من كوريا الشمالية،
فسيتعين عليهم السفر مسافة طويلة جدًا
للوصول إلى خط المواجهة الأوكراني، لكن
هذه هي الأشياء التي
يطلبها بوتين حقًا، وكما نرى
في هذه الرسالة
قد يكون هناك موقف سياسي من الولايات المتحدة
هنا، حيث يريدون إظهار أن
لديهم حلفاء وأن لديهم طرقًا للحصول على
المزيد من الدعم لإطالة أمد هذا الصراع
وتجديد خطوطهم الأمامية،
وهذا أمر يجب على
حلفاء أوكرانيا أن يقلقوا بشأنه.